happened
are we rolling pap
okay I have been wildly tacky uh this
morning
um Trevor Wallace showed up at the time
he was supposed to be here at 11 time
yeah rare yeah but you know the saying
if you're on time you're late then you
were on Time in Forever 21 t-shirts
right now
if you're not on time so you're not on
the rhyme really quick I wore this for a
zoo meeting and now I need to change for
the podcast and I told Grace just grab
me a shirt she picked out my shirt and I
don't even know what it is it's good
she's sabotaging me no it's great
Moroccan vibes
[Music]
this is what Grace has chosen for me
because she's sabotaged me on a daily
basis to hopefully Dethrone me and take
over how did you pick use one in the
closet and you just look at the shirt
she's wearing I went into your closet
first of all how did you know the shirt
was in here
which is Labyrinthian and I uh went to
the furthest rack and I reached into the
very Corner multiple racks there's so
much closet we've got I've got an animal
just animal rack that's just animals oh
animal but fake fake but is this
appropriation of African culture
probably yeah if you have to ask
like does this feel like I shouldn't be
wearing you were almost wearing a Lisa
Frank nightgown so yeah I'm just saying
but this am I gonna get in trouble no
you look like you work at Rainforest
Cafe it's beautiful I feel like the fun
hostess I feel like this was like Steve
Harvey's pajamas when he was in his 20s
not baggy enough it's probably way bad
years the real king of comedy baby
Trevor Wallace hey what the hell man I'm
excited to be here this is fun our
episode came out today uh you on our
podcast to socks lovely how was that
he's doing you were there
even more so that's good people are
loving it really yeah I don't know are
your fans like queuing on Bros uh uh nah
they're they're just they're just
excited that a woman is talking to them
because they think that it's you know
it's it's like a podcast you know they
feel like they're being in the same room
as you so they're like oh is that what
podcast is
um somewhat okay what could you help me
understand so a podcast is uh where you
talk about nothing for an hour and a
half and then you plug erectile
dysfunction pills Midway through and you
go ladies and gentlemen use the
Bluetooth ad promo code sucks if you
snap one more time I am going to break
your fucking fingers I have frail
fingers uh you really do you have ET you
have Ed Al Dente fingers E.T fingers ET
fingers this one lights up actually yeah
you probably are good at fingering I
actually I'm not
how do you know how do I know women have
told me she's like what are you fucking
ringing a doorbell down there I don't
but but then the the last girl I was
with I was like I was joking like she
she like made a comment about I was like
oh teach me and she's like what she's
like you're a grown adult like learn and
I was like no no every woman's vagina is
different if you learn hers because
here's what I love when
um a guy like really thinks he knows
what he's doing and just like goes for
it he's like does this week's week
whatever and then left right square B
yeah I remember one time I said to a guy
and I didn't realize how it was it may
or may not have been
um who's I don't want to be anything
other than that his brother uh hooking
up with him yeah one time I literally
said out loud I was like what are you
looking for oh God and I I in my head I
was like oh maybe he's looking for like
a G-spot or the IUD or I don't like to
make sure I have an IUD it felt like he
was trying to feel if I had an IUD in
and I was like what do you and then and
then I realized that was what are you
looking you could spin that on anyway
because if he was like what the fuck you
could be like I mean there's a lot going
on down there what are you looking for I
mean because what did you find he needed
the E.T finger to see down there
that was a stinger I don't have health
insurance at the time so I'm like do you
feel alone
if you feel something weird like I would
love to no what did he say back to that
but I don't know he's shit-faced that
was like a running joke for like it
still is on the podcast but Trevor
doesn't know how to finger we had Lisa
and the porn star on and we we had like
grapefruits and she was like oh here's
how you do it and then I already know
you're bad at what you're doing right
now oh yeah well I'm throwing up fucking
half the blood symbol right here no I
believe that's not the white power
symbol so hey come on umbrella insurance
I'm Jewish leave me alone
but when a guy is very proficient at
fingering or something what they don't
understand is their professional doing
it on their ex so they'll go and do the
thing and I'm like
great I now know exactly how your ex has
an orgasm I know more about her than I
ever needed to know now you kind of have
to start from scratch because every
vagina is different the buttons are in
different places and yeah it's like kind
of when you get in a friend's car you're
like wow they drove fucking weird that's
funny
that's so funny what are you looking for
why every time I get to a friend of
mine's going to get in the passenger
seat then you're just like
why why is everybody driving like an
Uber driver
everybody's on ultimas come this far
back in the chairs this the only car you
ever see somebody driving like this you
ever been in the back of an Uber where
the guy doesn't scoot up and you're like
hey would you mind if you could just oh
no it's fine it's only 47 minutes whoa
feed you're just giving those away for
free actually do you know what the deal
is with my feet is that I have a five on
Wiki feet five out of five but I want to
get my score down to zero
so I've been posting photos of I've like
when I have really bad anxiety and OCD I
dig into my toes until they bleed
want to suck them yeah
and then so now I'm trying to get my
wikifee score uh Wiki feet to zero and
then Pat is on the what is it armpit
feet um we bought wikipits.com last
night Wiki pits this is people's armpits
you bought it you own it I guess so but
I'll pull it up that's the new crypto
please do I mean but that is funny that
people used to buy like like
trevorwallscomedy.com or trevorwalls.com
is like way more expensive than it was
you know three years ago why not just
trevorwallis.com it was like twelve
thousand dollars okay well Trevor lost
comedy by the way by the way get it it's
worth it yeah I don't know if you heard
that
you should do Trevor walls yucks if
anything else so yeah we got this is all
gonna be armpits I think I have pretty
good armpits they're a little flat
they're not very pity are they supposed
to be wikipits.com
um
that is so ridiculous bad I like the tag
at the bottom fucking nice pits that's
something if I was a woman getting cat
called she was like nice pits I bet come
here let me blow you come here I have to
blow you right now I'm fourth and
Broadway let me ask you
um okay did you get specific feedback
from one girl about this mainly yeah
fingering and it just traumatized you
because what if her pussy was broken
honestly I think it was her pussy might
have been weird she was like this was
something she told me she's like she's
like I can't come during sex and I was
like wait this is awesome and then I was
like have you fucked up millionaire
before but that's when I was like wait
what did like could your other exes like
like make you finish doing sex she's
like no no one I was like let me I need
to talk to them let me phone a friend
Regis get on hello region Who Wants To
Be A Millionaire where's my lifeline let
me talk to somebody who was your who did
you look up to when you were a kid
besides me
wind Cummings
um Jim Carrey Robin Williams sure Dave
Chappelle's early specials are like like
untouched everything like uh Nick
Swardson uh I thought seriously who
farted was like one of my favorite
comedy specials growing up but like
that's just my kindness schwartson is so
fucking funny yeah I mean you just want
to be he's one of those guys he's just
watching you're like oh really best
friends but he also just the way
everything he says is funny like it's
just he can't not be it also looks like
he's not trying and there's something
about when you look like you're not
trying they're like oh that's just he
just gets it it's so effortless he's
been doing it for seven years but you're
like these guys walked up and I was
talking about his Tuesday you know when
he was on the podcast I've never seen
him I've never seen you laugh that hard
he's the funniest he's so funny like he
kills me he kill I mean he's has to say
hello he's just like he's like hi like
you're just like yeah like he um a
couple things number one we were
shooting this thing for Netflix it was
like these little sort of like
interstitially kind of things and I
don't know what this I don't know why he
was in Christmas pajamas left for it and
he came in in full Christmas pajamas
with like trees and stuff and then he
walks in and Spades with me and we're
doing something and and we were just
like you know this was like February
right like had nothing to do with
Christmas yeah yeah and we were just
riffing yeah about something and I was
like finally like why are you wearing
Christmas pajamas he was like I just got
out of rehab I'm addicted to Christmas
I just got out of rehab and oh that's
what I said I said what four and he went
I'm addicted to Christmas that's great
but he's just he's not trying to be
funny he's just talking you should stop
by next time he does the podcast oh I'd
love to he he's cool we we've talked a
few times but he's somebody that like
somebody sent me a screenshot a couple
years ago and they're like do you see
the Nick Swardson just commented on your
Instagram I was like no fucking way and
I look and sure not feel like following
me I was like that's like a few of those
like there's been a few of those like
Falls we were like oh dude no this guy
what are the biggest follows for you the
follows that were like I made it
um wow uh when he comes when he comes
when he comes
um when Tim Tim Dillon started following
me on Twitter a couple years ago I was
like oh that's pretty fucking cool like
he's hilarious
um what are some other big ones some of
the guys from It's Always Sunny follow
me which is really cool oh yeah
um this guy that I look to up to a lot
when I was first started making videos
Jimmy Tatro he's a YouTube guy he he was
somebody when I saw the following I was
like oh fuck yeah you know it's somebody
who I think followed in their footsteps
so when they followed me I was like oh
nice that's cool
um and you were doing standard before
you were doing videos which I didn't
know and once I heard that I liked you
more why because you respect the game a
little bit yeah you know videos can take
you in in you know if you have a video
that goes viral you can be touring
fucking yuck yucks and you funny bones
all over in three months and then you'll
have you'll blow your brains out by 25.
yeah I mean it's so easy to if you have
a viral thing pop off you get a manager
and agent they're like you want to do
this live and you're like what am I
gonna do what's the number is it about
the engagement is about the number like
when do you know oh shit like I because
like it's hard to tell what number is
the number you know what I mean it's
like for what touring uh in like TV and
movies
and so I
go flying out the horse while flipping
me off with their Hooves when I leave
like how do you know like obviously I'm
able to go I go holy shit this guy's 10
million like obviously that's a lot but
then is it also the
exit because like yeah it's really the
engagement how do you know like when is
someone like okay this is what I'm doing
for a living I am is it when you get an
agent is it yeah I don't know because I
found some videos that do really well
and I'm like I'm not a content creator
like I couldn't do this every week twice
a week
yeah I don't know I I when like how do
you know when you're on or how do you
know when you can like tour like maybe
that's the question which one
first or second by the time you ask me
that you can answer both
bring the horses in
um I think
you know I don't I'm just curious like
when did you know like I fucking when I
knew is when I was doing spots on other
people's shows and I would promote it
and then I would have like you know I'd
be like doing like 10 minutes on like a
show like the Ontario Improv sure sure
you know and I would drive there after
work or something and I was there to see
you yeah and you know I would do like 10
minutes and then some you know other
person would be like 45 at the end
they'd be like oh do we you know we came
for you you know I saw like 10 minutes
of you man like we want to see more and
then you just kind of like you start
collecting and you go to San Diego now
there's the same people saying that's
you and you're like oh okay like 20 30
people said that to me and I barely
promoted this show oh maybe I can do you
know maybe maybe I can do one night or
the first like five or six headlining
gigs I booked like 2017 and I just
reached out to a venue one in San Diego
uh zany's in Chicago
um and a few of them I was just like
what's that accent which one Zanies uh
Adderall
[Music]
is it the release time release the
extended release yeah extended release
okay I don't take it a lot but you know
I had like four hours to kill when I got
here so I was just trying to figure out
something to do um I rearranged all of
your Linens alphabetical yeah
um my linens why are you acting like I
live in a nunnery
Whitney Whitney you act like there's not
a dude back there churning your butter
right now you're vegan butter no
slave who uses a butter churn to fuck me
that's tight now that's something you
should put on Wiki pits do you feel like
when you're doing stand-up your fans
from your videos are like Ben guy like
they want you to do it uh sometimes do
you feel like you have to oh I have a
few things that'll like reference it but
I don't want I want them to be two
separate like entities like I don't
because you know there's some cities
where I don't sell at all and then
there's random people which cities let's
fucking Jacksonville Florida what the
fuck Jacksonville what's up with y'all
meth math yeah it's weird because the
meth thing I'm like like from what I
understand my method really I feel like
you'd be at the show two hours early
helping set up but um no but but I mean
maybe this is just me underselling
myself but I want somebody if they have
no idea what the fuck the internet is
they have no idea what Tick Tock is
they've they're the last impression is
like I was on somebody's top eight once
in 2004 you know like I want them to
discreet can opening uh I want somebody
to show up to and be like oh this is
just a comedy show it doesn't matter if
this guy has one follower or like
millions of followers and I want them to
just kind of like what is this thing
this thing I don't know what maybe it's
just you got so famous and successful so
young it's the idea of like everybody
knows me I really want the people that
don't know me to just see me for just a
guide
um I don't know but I think that's maybe
just kind of like the stand-up side of
things oh interesting because like when
I first started in stand it was like you
nobody knew you but you're like I just
want to be funny I just want to be the
funniest guy in the lineup yeah yeah so
I do things starting with stand up first
really helped me kind of understand the
art of comedy and not just jumping
through those hoops and the Art of
bombing and the Art of like being
appreciative to go on the road with
somebody and to like open for somebody
for like five shows at a casino in
Riverside you're like just fucking time
I get to do 25 minutes yeah I'm booked
on a weekend I remember when I got my
first hotel
that was paid for by comedy it was at
some Casino up in the middle of
California and I was ecstatic I like
somewhere probably have a video I like
remember like recording the Ruby like
fucking you're getting paid to just do
stand-up yeah I did 10 minutes I drove
the future and the host there something
that may sound like an insult is coming
and it's not an insult just
is it about my nose
no I bet you're great at eating pussy
because of that nose though that was how
I'd get the last girl off yeah that was
I couldn't figure something let me just
bust out the snorkel
that clip with your nose like
look this boy's got a fucking Hemi in it
can I tell you something no this is um
uh uh what are they called what's up
when something's pronounced pronounced
nose on a man is hotter really bald and
nose yeah so just shave your head and
you are the hottest man alive bald
statistically yeah because I know I
would look like a fucking pyramid are
you kidding me if I was like bald I look
like the damn Seahawks logo you want me
to just you think you're you're the bald
guys uh I'm into guys that don't care
about their appearance
interesting yeah if a guy thinks he's
hot it's just it makes me like
physically ill it is hilarious for
that's how my co-host Michael he's like
I'm like Jack I'm like that's hilarious
to say it's just like a guy someone that
no I mean and here's the thing what I'll
say is I feel like everyone with women
now is like love yourself you're hot
you're a queen so that like someone that
knows insurance
hey cunt there you go um cut it out I
guess it's just like anyone that knows
they're hot and I don't know what this
is or maybe it's some shame in me anyone
that's like really feeling themselves
I'm a little bit like it's just a little
repellent that's the only thing worse
than that is someone's like I'm ugly and
I'm fat and they're not and you're like
you're stuck you know so well because
that's fishing for compliments for
somebody to be like you're not ugly
you're better yeah yeah yeah exactly I
like a nice middle ground but give me
both you're like I'm having a great hair
day but boy am I about to blow up this
bathroom afterwards you know like the
awareness of like I'm hot but I'm also
human yeah when um how do we get what
are we talking about I like your brain I
like your brain you're just very
self-aware you're incredibly smart
um your nose is just a like a pussy wand
um and
but knows this there was a scientific
study that came out that guys with more
prominent noses are more attractive on
like a primordial level like
subconscious level and who wrote that a
guy with a fucked up nose
he's decided how did we get on the top
you were like oh I'm gonna give you a
compliment but I'm going to tell you
something but it's not a compliment but
it's not you what I'm saying uh you're
like I'm gonna tell you something and
it's gonna sound fucked up but it's not
um that's everything I've say just in
general that doesn't narrow it down but
yes which is oh this which is when I
there's a new sort of weird curse around
you know comedians stand-up comedians
but most influencers or most content
creators weren't stand-ups at first you
got incredibly famous and successful as
a content creator and as a comedian I
saw you somewhere during the pandemic
maybe and I remember going like ah here
we go but that's that's something which
by the way I would do to probably anyone
even if they're not because that's why I
feel like I always want to do my best
one especially it's like somebody like
you know you were or other like kind of
very established Comics I'm like
I don't ever want to like play to the
back of the room because you're like oh
you should care about is your fans but
there is that little nosh where it's
like oh notch
Nosh no Notch I'm not great with English
in your brain oh a notch yeah uh nodule
Nigel Thornberry
but there's that little like I don't
know insert word you want to use Nosh we
get it you're doing this yeah uh uh were
you where you want to be like oh
so-and-so oh Bill Burr's in the back man
maybe he holds to my set and then like
be like oh I know this guy that's who
you're actually doing stand up for so
it's like to me when someone's like oh
killed you're like yeah well that's your
job like did the comics in the back
think it was funny but I think it's not
even do they think I'm funny do they
think that I'm not trying to infringe on
their space where it's like oh this
internet guy thinks he can do stand-up
but then I just want them to see it and
be like oh he he's he's allowed to be
here he he is he he does stand up it's
not like he's just telling video stories
totally totally well because I think
it's all the type of venues I saw you at
in the beginning I was like oh this
guy's for real you know like you can
tell you can tell who's just trying to
Coast based on success from another
place and the people that are really
like yeah
because then I just keep seeing you and
being like this motherfucker will not
let up yeah this motherfucker is really
like and then I was like oh shit and
then I saw your videos and I was like oh
God he's funny that's really annoying
and he can't possibly also be funny and
stand up because if he's funny about
then I have no excuse to not be doing
what you're doing so I my ego needs him
to suck my ego needs this because then I
have no excuse to not be better at Tick
Tock yeah and then you're funny too and
then humble and so what is it what is it
what's your weird what is it
what do you mean like what like what's
off about me I can't really I can't
finger a woman
but here's something here's what I'll
say there's no wrong way to figure the
fingering
fingers bring it up the fingering the
whole point of fingering is just like
it's what the dick is about to do
you don't have to scoop so that I'm
squirting everywhere I don't need to pee
on you like it's you didn't do it right
if you don't need to but if you want if
you did it deeply wrong I'm pissing on
you you know this whole thing about I
need to get her to piss on me and squirt
everything like why why do you hate your
mattress why do you hate your Helix
mattress uh promo code Whitney or socks
whatever you want to use anyway
um but yeah so I'm just curious it does
seem like what is your longest
relationship two and a half years oh
that's a long time yeah can I ask why it
ended
um I think it's right person wrong time
I think we're just both in this very
developmental part of our like careers
where she was getting bombarded at work
like she worked in finance worked crazy
hours and she would get home at like
seven then I'd be leaving for spots yeah
like eight yeah to me is the perfect
relationship but okay yeah but I think
there's some I think in a mature uh I
think when you're a little older you
understand but like we're both kind of
like young you know she's 26 I'm 29 so
oh yeah you just both wanted to be like
it's the weekend why can't I hang out
with my boyfriend oh he's in fucking
Arkansas right now yeah so it's like
right person wrong time it's just like
you kind of you just picked the only
place there's no Comedy Club oh there's
definitely one a little is there you're
just too famous to know that you don't
know that there's people in Arkansas
okay I don't that because here's what it
because it made me go like oh she's like
why is he in Arkansas there's no comedy
clubs there this can't be good baby they
got a fucking loony band or whatever the
hell probably
um but yeah it was just that I mean
she's still a great person we're on good
terms but yeah and we still talk like a
lot but what are in the dating scene
what's a red flag on someone's dating
profile here's what I he I is profile if
somebody says I'm funnier than new no
you're not I get paid for it shut up
look at my net worth
it's not much but but also you're a
woman how funny could you be but um
I don't um I think it's like that
stereotype of like kind of like where
immediately you need to like put that
person down oh you do a comedy tell me a
joke oh I'm funnier than you this and
that it's just like can we just be
normal humans can we just real quick ask
each other what their favorite place to
get a nice gluten-free pasta in town is
why do we immediately have to jump shit
and be like I'm funnier than you really
you work in HR at fucking Geico okay
taking a quick much-needed break from
Trevor being funnier than me
to talk about tour dates Cincinnati Ohio
September 8th I will be there at the
Taft theater September 9th I'll be in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania at the Miller
Theater then I'm coming to Richmond
September 10th at the national my aunt
who kind of raised me is going to be
there so watch me watch me try to
perform an entire hour of the kind of
shit I talk about with my aunt sitting
side stage I'm gonna come to that and
give her some feedback give her feedback
on what anything good about me she did
okay well then that'll be good but but
like smashing car windows to get dogs
out even if the car door is unlocked
that is her though okay yeah yeah okay
so I'm sure you'll have a couple what do
you want me to give can you give me your
mom's phone number you're never gonna be
my mom okay I think that's true I
actually think that's true I would you
know I would never I know I know so on
the uh I'll be at the National Theater
September 24th that's September 24th in
Charlottesville at the Paramount Theater
I was going to get to that no you said
September 21 worth at the national but
that's September 10th
can you just mine whitneycummings.com
you know just mind your own business I
know you hate it when I try to get the
accurate information to the people that
want to come see you're taking away
their ability to have a fun scavenger
hunt
you're taking away my no I'm taking away
the ability of someone living in
Charlottesville showing up at the
national in Richmond at the wrong time
that sounds like a great road trip that
sounds like a buddy comedy in the making
I love that you think people have any
idea when or where any shows are even
when I say it correctly I'll get 90
fucking wait so it's at the Paramount
Theater right in Charlottesville right
September 20 are you sure it's September
25th like I don't know what to tell you
they also email me because you're like I
don't know email Grace yeah exactly like
just like I don't go to the website go
to Sarah silverman.com and figure it out
I'm also doing a club tour because clubs
is how you get better as a comedian I
love doing smaller venues so I can see
you guys in person and watch you roll
your eyes in the front row uh this is
called the I Club you tour because I
clubbed you in a club clubs October 21st
to 23rd I'm in San Jose California San
Jose Improv so I'll use Silicon Valley
Aspergers hunks come on down November
17th through 19th in Sacramento
California Sacramento punch line I
promise to have some punch Lines by then
uh November 25th and 26th Phoenix
Arizona stand up live uh December 9th uh
through 11th I'm in Oxnard California
Oxnard Levity Live which is actually
pretty near La so take a Molly and let's
go okay don't you can you if you can
drive to Coachella you can come to
Oxnard California I'm gonna drive there
to see Nick Swardson
we all come okay
Richard where are you gonna be uh
February
uh yes I am going to be and Valentine oh
my God I'm performing you're doing a
Valentine's Day special
not far from here I am in Irvine
February 10th through 14th I will be at
a literally next to a fucking American
Eagle Outfitters on Valentine's Day and
then we are doing a live show for you
guys for my birthday my birthday
September 4th all right with us I would
love nothing more than to get myself
canceled on a live show Tuesday
September 6th uh 6 p.m PT Pacific time
so nine okay on the East Coast
um send us happy birthday videos okay uh
stuff we're gonna play because we need
stuff to play on the live show they're
gonna surprise me with birthday videos
burning questions go to good for youfans
gmail.com email that site yes and we'll
put the site to get tickets on the
bottom and if you don't send me a
birthday thing don't fuck with me
anymore that's fine you know what I mean
yeah yeah I feel like if you listen to
this podcast you're my friend and it'd
be weird for you to not wish me a happy
birthday that's true think yeah and like
send us a video send a video writing
yeah just engage it could just be dumb
or stupid or like if you know we were in
person what you would get like just show
me you're an impression just show me
your house you guys you know I just want
to see your bathrooms you know I just
love bathroom I love looking you
actually like stick pics yeah just so I
can that is I do my whole thing is I
love dick pics when I go in the H3
podcast I'm like send me dick pics
because it's really just the only way I
get to see people's bathrooms yeah it's
I'm fascinated I'm like they still make
Head and Shoulders with the Irish Spring
always you know that Irish Spring gets
stuck to the I know a comment remember
Comet no all right so guys get tickets
moment dot Co slash good for you tickets
are on sale now we're so excited maybe
we'll make Trevor join great that would
be fun he's really funny yeah yeah okay
we'll text him hey you guys
it's summertime it's actually
always summertime uh because of what
we've done in the environment but it is
also summertime the days are hot the
grill is going it is the perfect time to
enjoy some wine with friends or family
because how else can you tolerate family
family's whining without a little wine
but did you know that summer heat and
sunlight can spoil not only your skin
Grace but also your wine
and your good times if it's not properly
stored imagine going to buy this
beautiful bottle of wine and the Sun
comes in and just room makes it taste
makes it taste like turns it into
raisins yeah gross it's time to get
those bottles out of boxes off your
countertops or my case out of the
backseat of your car Wine Enthusiast
designs and offers the largest selection
of wine coolers for every Drinker every
budget and every size collection from 6
to 600 bottles plus expert wine storage
Consultants are available by phone to
help you find the right
fit for all your needs for a second I
thought that said tilt and I was like am
I tilting my wine wrong I mean I
probably am Wine Enthusiast is the
premiere destination for the wine
lifestyle also known as the people who
get it offering an incredible selection
of unique wine accessories glassware
Furniture wine storage gifts and more
visit wine enthusiast.com or text the
code gfy that's the acronym for our um
podcast not a new STD to 5 11 5 11. from
now until Labor Day save during wine
enthusiast Labor Day Sale save up to 50
off that's wild so it's half off yeah
select wine cellars and Furniture now
through Labor Day text g f y to 511 511
I said that even though I'm dyslexic and
drink wine all day text gfy to 511 511
today wine enthusiast.com they bring
wine to life certain Solutions May apply
you may receive up to one additional
text message and tutor rates may apply
text text stop to opt out but that would
be ridiculous back to Trevor what's this
is a snack is this a program what time
is it no I do 12 32 snack
you just have somebody who brings you a
t-shirt that looks like it was on a
child's rug for sure like you would ride
trains on and somebody brings you a
neutral game bar what do I get one are
you hungry because I mean you I just
need to eat something I have not eaten
all day and your brain I love how you're
just really opening the wrapper but it's
the last no but here's the deal don't
worry I'll plug tour dates while you're
eating so we're going to be in Boise
Idaho Las Vegas Madison Oxnard I'm
kidding no no keep going keep going um
Fort Lauderdale Charleston Asheville
Phoenix San Francisco loudest rap
wherever Houston Grand Rapids
Indianapolis Cleveland Salt Lake City
Boulder Fort Collins Oklahoma today
September 8th and then I'll be in
Charlotte and Richmond I also you can
buy all of Whitney's tickets at
trevorwallscomedy.com
I'm a huge fan if you want to sponsor my
tour I love what you do they're over
there white climb they would be like
Whitney is so profound she's got
umbrella Insurance she's great she knows
what the hell she's doing she's a good
can it she's white and all her friends
have paused true true and this is a wild
tour it this is the leg two of a tour so
these are a lot of the cities that we
didn't go to on the first one oh pitch
pitch
um in line for Supreme guy the height
Beast is very funny to me like waiting
in line at 2 A.M oh it's hilarious or a
fanny pack that's gonna be on eBay that
night yeah and you wear it and you don't
immediately just get head from a
stranger like why are you why are you
wearing a supreme but it's like it's
that's why Fashion's so funny but he's
like you buy you wait all this time you
spend 750 on a Gucci t-shirt you wear to
a club just for a girl to say like oh
I'm all right return the shirt this is
so dumb but a guy who calls people Chief
no that's funny like you can just it can
just be like
what's up chief for like a minute just
to do for people the Chiefs to Native
Americans to like to everyone literally
actually yeah
actually but it is funny and in a
scenario where you don't need it like
you know why is the guy you're renting a
car from like thanks Chief it's like
what are we doing here I I do think it
is there's I can read some ideas that I
write down just to you give me yeah I
just love please do I love this because
what you're doing is you're doing
basically Jerry Seinfeld it's like these
super tiny observations that it's
they're so ubiquitous and everywhere
that you almost don't notice them but as
soon as someone points it out you're
like oh like it's just like that's
usually when I get an idea in my head it
goes is this a video or is this stand up
and sometimes you go this would be so
much better as a video but just because
it's Visual and I've done videos where
they used to be standing bits or I'm
like ah this would have been better at
standing I'm doing a bit right now that
um will be I would have pitched you if I
wasn't doing it which is um uh guys who
do their own research funny do their own
research you know what I mean yeah like
uh you're like ah this thing in Ukraine
where'd you read that Snapchat oh I got
it off but I'll do I do my own research
yeah I watch CNN I watch box and then I
and then what yeah and then how do you
know which one is true I it feels true
like I'll know or and guy who um guy who
gets his news from some guy on YouTube
yeah just some guy who the more publicly
disgraced their thought leader is the
smarter they have decided they but you
gotta check this guy out dude he has
been banned from three universities
kicked off YouTube removed from the
Instagram banned from four countries
dude you got this guy knows some shit
yeah you got to go to tubeyou.com not
even YouTube to watch his shit tube you
uh I'll read you some of these and see
if any of these land um and these are
all over the place what I want to do is
uh guys was self-employed in their bio I
think that's funny just saying that
you're self-employed you sell uh Pokemon
cards in Adderall at the same time but
also self-employed like because no one
else was interested but but it's like
the same people like I'm a hustle I'm a
motivated I do this on my own uh I do I
don't know where the funny is on this
but I think it's really funny people who
post ice Baths on Instagram it's very
nice bath guy yeah but there's just like
five video frames of them just being
like
like what do we what am I supposed to
how am I supposed to engage in this but
I bet your nips are rock hard dad what
am I supposed to do but here's what I
think that is I think also people video
it
to get through it you know what I mean
you're more likely to you don't have to
post it but I know but I this is I to me
what's funny about that is to go your
narcissism for being seen by other
people is the only that's everything
doing something painful becomes less
painful if if you're getting Cloud off
it like the thing that makes you be able
to tolerate this is knowing other people
are gonna like you that's what gets you
through that that's what's getting you
through it right you know what I'm
saying well like yeah I mean imagine
being on jackass and like Hey we're
actually not going to air this season
you're like what wait wait I the only
reason the only reason I suck that
horse's dick is because I I knew it was
gonna be on camera and you appreciate
the animal
it's the least we can do uh this is a
video I want to do uh when you don't
know what your ex has been up to you
ever talk to somebody where they're like
they're like dude how's uh Veronica I
don't really know I don't really keep up
with her I think she just got married or
like moved to like Wyoming or like she
has like two kids and like one of them
has like this weird allergy with like
macadamia nuts but not peanuts I don't
know but I haven't liked
the guy in the club bathroom who's like
uh has the mints and the candies don't
feel like obligated I that always
happens in Vegas where they're like men
cologne and you're like oh I'm good he's
like well you got at least you gotta
wash your hands and then they have the
paper towels for you I think there's
something there just how convincing they
are but I also think but also in the
women's room is so oh jacked up with
stuff no it's got so much stuff and like
Hairspray lipstick oh yeah I'm like how
much makeup do you think I need like
I'll tip you to not suggest this you're
making me insecure yeah guys it's funny
it's just like ax body spray and
Lifesaver men's just like just like your
car Noir yeah like what am I gonna
fucking RC car after this
um by the way that's so great because
it's like but I think it's funny that
now that there's more and more men's
stuff here's how that would go for me or
what my pitch would be that a super
confident guy comes into the bathroom
and then slowly over the next couple
minutes starts getting really insecure
about his appearance because the purse
is like eye cream yeah like lip balm
he's like no I don't need that teeth
whitening will be funny if a girl was in
the bathroom doing the yeah you know oh
yeah yeah totally okay keep going
yeah no uh let's see what else we got
here um but I want to do something I
don't know what the title of this would
be but it's like I think there's
something funny every time I see my
parents phone the font is bigger and
bigger and bigger and I just want to do
a video where I like keep looking over
and then they're just typing on Like a
Wheel of Fortune like size thing but
every time the font is just massive uh
let's see here we got uh thoughtsworld
getting a massage I think that's a quick
one we ever make uh this is you're too
rich for this but you ever make like you
ever make eye contact with your post
maze driver
like like this you think I don't make
icon do you don't think I see my
Postmates driver no or talk to them no
I think you have the ballet boy go out
front he does he's Venezuelan he doesn't
speak English and then he just holds up
before I believe will you defend me he
holds up a photo of you and then goes
in points and goes her the guy goes yes
and then they take whatever the fuck you
order from Sugarfish because there's no
way you're not getting anything less
than sugar fish actually do you eat
sushi I do okay it's actually pretty
self-sufficient I yeah much more than
other people I've worked for she
goes Rogue and she once invited a
Postmates driver into her home and like
talking that's because she was alone oh
remember that everyone was like what are
you doing I was like he just moved to LA
like we're going to help him like I was
for sure thought that like this was porn
we're in the valley his hot chicken my
like I'm like snobbier than Whitney
about things just from my like Hollywood
adjacentness we can do that ourselves
I'm like no we can't so use that
notification they like they like send
you the photo that your food is out
front and then I have this little gate
and I open it and then I just grab it
and we just like lock eyes for a second
and I just feel like that intimate
moment where you like block eyes I just
feel like you're at your worst and
they're just looking at you you're
wearing half a rope from the waist down
you're just like I'm not like I'm better
than this and the driver's looking at
you like the restaurant was 0.2 miles
away man you're gonna walk to get it I
have a zoom call in an hour you just
feel like you need to justify yourself
or
um this is an old stand-up bit that I
should probably bring back but it's like
when you try to seem busy when when they
like call you like hey I'm out like
you're posting driver calls you and you
don't answer on the first second or
third ring because you're just waiting
for you you want them to feel like
you're busy that's why you did Postmates
it's not like you weren't tracking them
for the past fucking five miles I know
every turn I know you missed that U-turn
on La Cienega but I'm watching you be
like you're here oh yeah
um yeah I'll be down in a sec you're
ending Zoom calls you're not even on
yeah yeah Lauren look you're so good for
SNL next week I'll be right now but then
it's like you were literally watching
him the whole time and then you're like
out front like you're trying to be this
like Hustler guy whereas you were
watching him drive around the
neighborhood they call you I know you're
on my street I mean every time because
they say like oh it'll be here around
like 1 30 and you start checking 125
you're like the amount of times that I
check I could have just got the food
myself how about the guy um who wears uh
hats with the sticker still on it and
everyone's like oh you're the sticker's
on I'm still on it yeah oh no I know
yeah like that because it's always that
it's like oh I think you forgot to take
that no it's
yeah this is a thing what it just
confuses Everything 100 I'm trying to
think that's kind of funny like stuff
like that when like a trend it's little
niche stuff I think so too yeah one
video I did that I like do you have a
water bottle guy uh I did one with the
motivational water bottle okay with like
the the different time stamps on it yeah
I wanted to do one of those it was just
like about like division one athletes
and then each time you see him the water
bottle gets bigger and bigger just
because they always like I went to uh a
state school and there was a football
team there and like these guys would
just walk into class with like like
enough water for like a small village
like it was an insane amount but like
they're just sitting there I'm like how
do you not have to pee 14 minutes and
then when they go to drink it they're
like
but yeah it's this whole thing and I'm
like you guys aren't you're not gonna do
the homework you're not here to learn
and by the way the big water bottle
thing it's also just like they leave it
everywhere and it's so every it's
everyone else's responsibility so after
work everyone's like have you seen Jim's
water bottle and do you have as well and
we're like yeah you don't even drink
from it also you ever got stuck behind
that guy at the gym when he's filling up
in front of you fuck am I supposed to do
here I want to do one about uh your
friend who always has loose Hydro flasks
in the car every turn they make
and then you're like I tried to film one
day but it didn't come out great here's
another one that annoys me just a random
one uh what's your birthday December
30th December 2nd really my sister's
December 4th no but see that's not
what when people when people when people
give you the birthdays then it's close
that wasn't close that was four weeks
apart when people try to connect too
hard people who are just obsessed with
their birthday I don't like when people
when you have the same name you feel
like you have to bond over something but
or for traveling like oh dude I'm also
Trevor and you're like oh cool should we
go fuck each other's girlfriends
that's always a weird one cool should we
exchange embroidered clothes for sure do
I get free pepper jack cheese on my
burger or nothing
I do people do that with their birthdays
too and it has zero the people that are
just obsessed with their birthday like
it's just like they're just looking for
they'll ask you your birthday because
they just want to tell you there yes
when's your birthday holiday
oh my God December 30th January 5th dude
that's my cousin that's like so good it
is no oh yeah I was leaning into it by
the way why do you know your I don't
know any of my cousin's birthday I
actually think my cousin's birthday is
December 15th shout out Tyler hi Ty I
like the idea of guy guy who's um
super into cooking but only if it's
super dangerous okay guys will cook if
it removes like fire and knives and
like meat I I think a lot of it is just
like posting it online too feel like I
need to let women know who follow me
they're like Deacon sustain for himself
sure chicken breasts broccoli
but brown rice to put in the microwave
from Trader Joe's guys this guy can
survive guy who's trying to get a
nickname to work that won't catch on
then he's trying it right I had to go
like hey I'm sunny I thought her name
was Nick yeah it's sunny now I I close
to that a friend of mine was trying to
get this catchphrase to catch on love it
he's a comedian but he was like instead
of saying like like a lot of times if I
agree with you about oh dude 100 you say
100p oh no 100p no he's an audit 100p no
you're not in that you're not that busy
100p you got 100 feet but if you're if
you need to abbreviate that you need to
look into your time management skills if
you're so busy I just said I said 100
but he said 100 I like that 100 I'm I
say all the time but but he said 100p
and and it kind of like that's a weird
one right and then I didn't I didn't
like call it out and then later on he
said it's like a different comedian I
was like oh this is in his repertoire
he's trying to make this work he's ready
to agree with you I remember I did uh
Todd hi Todd
um you nerd yeah but that was like one
that was like the last this was I for
the TV show I did on NBC we had foreign
one of the characters was trying to make
a catchphrase happen like that was his
whole thing oh uh Dan O'Brien's
character
was this was it your show Winnie in my
show yeah okay this isn't like I think
the first season he was trying to make a
catchphrase happen and uh we were
brainstorming on the catchphrase it was
that was the most fun thing to do but we
landed on wheels up like every time
we're like let's head out he got wheels
up honestly you're gonna hate me for
this that could be good it's kind of
good wheels up anytime I'd be like oh
should we hit this restaurant wheels up
I mean anything is better than a guy
being literally let's fucking go you
know I'm that guy that's me let's
fucking go yeah but that's your
personality it matches it doesn't feel
like you're forcing it but I love it
when someone is like trying to make a
nickname work for them because they're
ready to I'm trying to think this I've
heard of the like catchphrases that I've
tried to catch on yeah they're like hey
I'm Jazzy someone's Like Richard like
it's just like what are you doing yeah
how do you feel about guys that have
like uh let's say the names like Matthew
but they go by like Maddie at like 37.
like or like people that have like Rich
their name is richer but they go by
Richie how do you feel about the IE or
the Y I believe at the age of 40 as a
man you go back to whatever the fuck was
on your birth certificate 40's given
some take there that's that's some
leeway
yeah I mean you don't do your your 37
going by Smitty we're in La so I'm
trying to be generous but um but also
um no logos no hoodies there's a point
where you gotta call it I do the hoodies
at what age no uh branded hoodies unless
it's
Trevor March
um but that's what's tricky to me or the
hoodie with a Blazer over it to be it's
like did you yeah yeah so did you buy a
smaller hoodie because you knew it was
gonna go over a Blazers magazine once
and like that's me but did you buy a
smaller hoodie so it would fit under a
Blazer my girlfriend's hoodie don't
worry and a bigger size blazer because
you knew it was going over a hoodie
where did you just have a hoodie and a
blazer and happen to work I never really
take fashion risks then every time I do
I feel it I go ah this ain't me yeah I
want to watch this interaction I had and
I would love to know your opinion I met
this guy at a at The Comedy Store
actually outside and walks out and he
goes hey what's up man you're Trevor I
was like hey what's going on I go to
shake his hand and he goes oh we don't
do handshakes around here we do peace
signs I'm Oliver and I was like this is
not a real what this is not a real
person and like I was like baffled but
what pissed me off is I did something
back who's we me and all my other voices
in my head I'm saying but you and Oliver
who's we we do peace signs yeah that's
what he's saying but but like whoever
the fuck whatever cult he's from we do
peace signs around here and I was so mad
because I did one back without even
noticing I was like oh all right you
idiot and I try to like shake his hand
but it was like it was like this weird
100 you were like 100p yeah exactly the
first thing he goes all over I was like
well change that and then he goes we do
peace signs around and it was just it
happened so quick I was like this is a
real person but you meet people in this
town that are like I'm dragging you're
like well what's the government name huh
Julian Julian that's funny because the
guy named blade like literally
everything just go around a Home Depot
and there's a guy named two by four
there's like there's everything out
there it's hilarious my favorite
interaction ever had when I first moved
to LA was wingman is my friend
um and I go to ask this girl I was like
oh what do you do out here and she goes
um I don't know breathe
and I was like by the way if you want
there's I was doing a joke about women
who uh have a tattoo that says breathe
like you have to be reminded to do an
involuntary thing like that is a rad
fucking Flag I also am sort of obsessed
with I mean this won't work for you but
um uh or maybe um because you could
start building this out and having like
a cast you know whatever but the idea of
um
people that uh whose parents obviously
did not want them to be gay and I can
tell by the way they were named when
someone's like hey Hunter
like a gay guy who's like I'm Gunner oh
man your parents your dad really wanted
him my middle name is John Deere
is that one word or two no like but you
can call me sassy and I'm like oh your
dad must be so fucking bummed that's a
funny problem you know something with a
kid named Hunter growing up he used to
read gun magazines at school swear to
God
gun magazines okay yeah I remember uh I
remember he was literally just reading a
gun magazine isn't that weird because
sorry a magazine is a is also the
bullets come in a magazine right there
you go hold on you had a thing that was
like uh does something once what was
your last video before white or has
white cloud once was that what it is
yeah yeah I like the idea of like
listens to Joe Rogan once yeah you know
what I mean the guy who's like just the
guy who's like you know the dog you know
dogs what they just regurgitate I want
to do one a guy who heard a thing on a
podcast guy heard a guy heard a thing on
a podcast and acts like he read a book
yeah yeah exactly but it's like they
hear one guy they look up to say it's
kind of we were saying like the
influential guy earlier but it's like
they start every sentence with yeah dude
I heard on this like podcast actually
that um bumblebees aren't actually on
bumble you're like oh for sure this
guy's very it's Source but I think the
idea of also going that like there used
to be Bros right there used to be jocks
and there were nerds that's what happens
when they run out of music genres to
like they go I'm gonna listen to
audiobooks and podcasts and then I'm
gonna regurgitate everything else I
think it's like they also finally like
have something to talk about at the gym
or whatever but it's like there were
jocks and there were nerds now there's
like nerdy jocks there's like cerebral
Bros so it was like well you know in
tribal times you know the reason that
we're doing so well with eating and like
you know you actually can't digest
things that were a banana because that's
not indigenous to so I mean it's funny I
overheard a date I was sitting next to a
date next to me at this like small
Italian place maybe a couple months ago
and I think it was the first date you
could tell the energy was off and the
guy like every like four or five senses
would be like yeah I hear this podcast
where and I was like oh this guy's
getting zero pussy tonight no girls ever
been like what one just say I read
tigerbelly
what did you hear what did you hear us
exactly I feel like there's no like like
I don't know I don't know maybe that
turns people on but like I I don't know
if if the girls would cross like oh my
God I'm just like oh you have an iPhone
good this is good this is good news so
you hate your job and you binge hours of
this podcast
do you listen to uh I listened to
flagrant was really good I like I like
Tim's and uh Theos probably
and of course good for you
all right
and honestly I listen to my own podcast
a lot from now on
um can you keep a tally a hundred
dollars for every time you snap
this money comes from you
oh wait no you pay me every time okay
I'm broke
I I do love my hands no so do I no it's
really it's the sound from this as they
go the sound yeah oh hey there I would
like to talk to you real quick about
newly so newly okay is this incredible
company that I've been dying to work
with it is basically your choice of any
six Styles each month you choose
whatever you want to rent this is so
genius because clothing is incredible
and newly has access to thousands of
styles for more than 300 Brands
everything from party dresses to premium
Denim and one-of-a-kind vintage pieces
they're vintage is really good no ways
but that I won't give back newly stock
Styles in a range of sizes from petite
to Plus Sizes up to five X Plus
maternity that's sick they carry labels
like for love which anyone is now
because Roe v Wade was uh overturned so
we're gonna need more and more of that
love shack Fancy Free People
anthropology and more I went on newly
and I found some things for you I went
to newly.com and I said what does
Whitney wear and I said I just searched
um horses okay I just searched I just
searched horses and the first thing that
came up actually this is so cute oh it's
a cut off day I saw it and I said so
yeah that's great but I have to give it
back you do have to give it back well
you do have the option to buy what you
love and keep forever oh my God yes it's
fast free shipping and return there's so
much more
there's just like so many that is so you
it's fast free shipping and returns and
professional cleaning and newly
state-of-the-art laundry facility
because you know my laundry for you to
worry about the way I describe my style
is
um one of the children from stranger
things exactly you could buy that and
keep it for up to 70 off sometimes
yeah or you could buy this other horse
sweater that I found
um it's a teal zip up sweater that just
has a horse it's like needle point it
just has horses and a gate how cute is
that no way wear it all at once yeah
dude I'm obsessed are you telling me I'm
not gonna be going to Etsy anymore yeah
correct you're just gonna be going to
newly oh wow oh wow oh wow it looks like
you already own that I can't believe
this is something did you get this out
of my closet no shockingly no I got it
on New Link newly has everything you
need to bring your closet at the speed
for the season stock up on a new dress
for every event without breaking the
bank say yes to all the current trends
Y2K Throwbacks or things that aren't in
style at all this is what I prefer
without feeling the fast fashion ick get
all the fashion you need while you need
it then let newly worry about where it
gets stored fall through spring dream
closet unlocked it's fun it's fun newly
is designed to give you everything you
need to get inspired get creative and
explore your style check out new trends
Silhouettes and sizes without any
commitments for your closet of only more
than once impulse purchases and buyers
remorse by renting instead maternity uh
plus post abortion I'm kidding maternity
plus post maternity post abortion
whatever you need newly carries
everything you need to get from just
popped to postpartum in style newly's
maternity and maternity friendly pieces
from labels like Ingrid and Isabel and
Hutch offer thoughtfully designed
features like nursing and pumping
friendly necklines and patented
supportive and cooling technology can I
get that even if I'm not pregnant I look
into it I'm
Bravo thank you so much I am blown away
newly is already a great value at 80 a
month for any six Styles but right now
you can get 10 off your first month of
newly when you sign up with the code
whitney10 just go to
n-u-uuly.com that's newlywith2us and
enter the code whitney10 and sign up to
get 10 off your first
knew you not nudie
get it you're not nude that's
n-u-u-l-y.com newly with two U's with
code Whitney 10 newly subscription
clothing rental change your clothes I
love the idea that you think like a uh a
clothing store in 2022's Hook is like
sick of being naked
we got you covered on your book of
Genesis shit lately not anymore are you
the emperor from Emperor's New Clothes
Chilly Willy over there with no threats
we got a threats just leave a nudist
colony
forget your worries back to this show
I'm obsessed Samsung guy do you have
Samsung guy Samsung Samsung the guy
who's like dude the camera on the side
oh like the Android the guy's trying to
get you to switch no you don't
understand dude dude I can zoom in on
people from India from my apartment in
Van Nuys that's always the camera stuff
it's always the camera stuff but it's
like the person who will die on that
hill with the Samsung yeah even though
it's the same person that's like apple
music is so much better than Spotify
you're like hey what is this for who are
you trying to impress what fucking
hipster chick in Silver Lake are you
trying to bang out that's the only
person
someone that just discovered boundaries
okay someone that just discovered the
concept of boundaries and is actually
just being a dick so the idea of a
boundary is like oh hey dude can you not
talk about my girl like that or like oh
hey do you mind if we don't talk about
like Trump again or you know but the guy
who just discovered who's like hey like
I really right now I just can you just
keep it down like someone I can't they
think they're doing self-care but
they're actually just being an asshole
amazing self-care yeah like hey guys do
you mind you know I know we're at a
nightclub it could be a lot of blinking
right now can you just like you're fuck
can you put your phone on silent it's
just like a lot it's distracting what
was the thing Miss Miss misophonia
misophonia what is the definition of it
basically means you hear things just
more Amplified you have like Super Hyper
Vigilant High hearing so it's like I'll
walk into a building sometimes and I'll
like hear like a loud
um like a buzzing or like and then I'll
like and then I remember one time the
person in the front desk was like you
hear it and I was like yeah do you hear
and he's like no but why is McDonald's
always so fucking loud there's always a
buzzing one else sounds like a plane is
about to land
nobody's ever waited at a McDonald's
like uh it's just it's ready turn off
the beepers guy that pretends to love
things women like so he can do things
women like guys like dude yoga is I'm
telling you man yoga is so it loosens up
your hip it's like you're you're kind of
ass just go you don't have to do this
you don't have to commit to it the bit
when you're not there yeah I this one is
dumb but I think it could do a quick one
uh how you think you look sending a
voice message versus reality you know
when you're you know you're like on the
move you're like tell them to meet me at
7 p.m tonight and you're like I'm
fucking Tom Cruise been a reality like
tell them to meet me no not neat meet me
uh let's see birds the day after you get
a car wash I just feel like they see a
dirty car like nah you get a car wash
and he's like I got a shit and then
listen there quick uh guys who use
military time it's a joke I used to talk
about it people whose military time that
aren't in the military I have a bit
about it but I do think there's a funny
video about it that is so funny because
it's like we got it you're good you have
to now you want so badly to seem tough
that you have to make everyone do math
all the time it's just the whole thing
about it it's just you're talking about
shit that doesn't need to have that like
cool connotation I got a date tonight
1900 where Iraq that is funny I think
that's good for stand up too yeah
because well then you could also do guys
that um wear a camouflage and they're
not going to war yeah right that whole
thing is like do you think I can't see
yeah legs the military time is just
funny because like and when I do it on
stage I'll be like you know the worse
than guys military time and then usually
some other girl like point out her
boyfriend they're like oh what are you
doing he's like oh front desk at H R
Block and you're like what I think he
does military time so his girlfriend
never knows actually what so he can go
that's not what I meant 8 P.M I said
eight babe I said
yeah yeah no no I told you I'd be home
in 2200 I wasn't cheating on you you
just suck at math yeah uh also it was
like weird just like you're trying to
dirty talk with it like come get this
dick in 1900
um all that is funny to me
um what about a
um someone that is doing a job for you
that's important who only talks about
how like I'm just doing this until I do
my the real thing I want to do Uber
drivers you know what I mean well
there's that but something important
like they'll get like someone who's
cutting your hair you know whatever
who's like I mean I don't even care like
you know I'm an actor you're like can
you just be a hair stylist right now
like or you know what I mean just like I
don't really wanna when you're trying to
get someone to do their job but you know
they don't love it and they really just
want to be a musician but it's like
really important yeah to you you could
just do that like as an inside joke and
just be like actors in LA and then that
you never once talk about acting really
you're just like yeah you know I'm just
driving until the screen plague is
picked up it's that box right now
there's just a lot of pages to review
but uh I did a video years ago that I
still like really liked just because I
thought the idea was funny when an Uber
driver picks up another Uber driver and
the boat's just in the car looking at
each other and then they're both like
I'm a screenplay Rider and then they're
like both I can't use other scripts like
headshots and then they're like I'm only
doing this until my job gets picked up
what about um magician I think there's
something funny with that I feel like
how they dress is so funny so I think
I'm doing a deal with only fans to do
because like we're at this time in
comedy where you're like where are we
gonna like I used to do the roast like
where are we gonna do like edgy joke
like where are we able to do all these
jokes that we're like have these super
power to write but it's too offensive
it's too dark it's punching down and I
was like where should roast Aliana bring
roasts back you know like four real
gnarly ones but it has to be behind a
paywall like should I do patreon once
and then um only fans asked me to do
their first like TV show yeah and I want
to do just instead of dirty photos and
dirty videos it's dirty jokes and it's
gonna be four roasts basically and it's
just gonna be like fucking wild that's
awesome you can't like yeah so fun I
want you to do one I would love to yeah
we used to do roast in our fraternity
every year they were like graduate the
roasted seniors and only the seniors and
like the cool guys did I did it as a
freshman when like nobody really knew me
in the fraternity they're like this kid
wants to do it and then I went up there
she's like yeah I loved it and then ever
since then I was doing it
um and they were just like my favorite
moment we'd all just like meet up we'd
like write jokes and like it was my
favorite maybe it'll be maybe I'll ask
swordson if we can roast Tim and he'll
because I'm looking at I think it's I
mean I was like Bobby Lee like it should
be our friend it's like roasts in the
beginning were the whole point of roses
was comics and Comics it wasn't like
comics and then like a famous model and
a famous celebrity and you know what I
mean it's like America's Got talents
like you want to see a couple people
bomb right the influencer with 12
million followers for showing her
areolas all right again I'm a dickhead
though I I feel like I because I'm you
know making it I feel like I'm not gonna
I don't wanna throw people I don't want
people like we'll set people up to win
like I used to be a writer for the rest
like I'll write great jokes for whoever
that's true can't you know like I did um
Josh Richards when they did the Bryce
Hall YouTube Bros
um they came and I wrote jokes with Josh
and it was like super fun he fucking
destroyed you that's great it's like I
don't it's interesting the bombing thing
yeah I don't have to think about that
because I don't want anyone I mean it's
here's the thing you can write a great
joke but if you don't know how to read
the joke and deliver it you know so so
even if you had some influence around or
something yeah the gold mine and they're
like yeah and then they just speed
through like it says like punch they re
they do some Joe Biden they read the
word punch take beat
he I forget what he said recently but he
it was like repeat I think he said the
words repeat phrase and that just I love
it dude fucking turn up
I I think it's I I just want to give my
pat on the head some days I would if
here's what I will say so because I'm a
comedian I always have to go the other
direction
um umbrella Insurance baby contrary with
no basis yet figuring out my take as
it's coming out of my mouth which is
like there's something kind of gangster
about that like if I want to invade
America and the guys like repeat phrase
I'm like Jesus like there's something
kind of like they're dealing with their
own shit like I don't even know like
honestly I do not want to fuck because
whoever's doing the Weekend at Bernie's
carrying this guy around is fucking
scary as shit yeah well it's like when
you see a celebrity start to lose their
mind on social media you're like uh he
he's got his own
last thing for real yeah so um annoying
things girls or guys do on socials that
is such a turn off let me give you a
couple please examples uh make comedy
videos kidding
um well when someone's like um doing an
Instagram story that no one like begged
them to do and they're like miserable
yeah they're like
hey guys
um
that's what you do off camera yeah yeah
you know what I'm saying like you don't
just get to be like
how do you feel about the fake
influencer like a girl who would just
tag a brand in it like thank you to
revolve for sending me this is like yeah
you paid for the shipping that's why
shipping works
but it's like it's a way to tell
everyone else that you get free stuff
and so wait a minute that is a business
move I I like I understand because in
the long run it could play out because
if you're when I started as a writer I'd
be like I have a project with this
person and I just met with this person
you exaggerate how far along it is
because there's no way to get that first
thing unless you've lied but I've seen
somebody like post they have like 700
followers but like for those of you
asking where my my top was from it's
from free people it's like the people
that are asking just DM them back it was
what it was your cousin being like Hey
where's that from then you're like hey
Instagram for those of you wondering
where it's from for most people if you
don't have a act or like a thing what
else are you gonna do
not talk about your bra but that's not
yeah I get it there's a very Pro girls
in their bras and their underwear and
making money
yeah no I'm just I'm saying I'm not even
saying about that that person I'm saying
that personality on social media but
girls are different I need to know where
your Top's from okay maybe I'm just
wrong yeah I will be like Furious if I
don't find out where the tops are you
know what I mean I just like like it
just annoys me because if it's something
from my hometown what's funny is like
somebody from my hometown will fall like
you guys do people do you know that it
is from Journeys but it's like they
follow like 50 people then they have
like 1 000 followers and they're like
it's like follow your classmates back
you see those people at Dunkin Donuts
daily but it's like I get that that if
if their career does take off and this
happens for people you gotta like you
gotta believe what I don't know you
gotta be like live the lifestyle you
want to live fake it till you make it
maybe I don't know but it's like they're
doing this because if they do become a
successful influencer they're like oh
I've always been that way uh I have one
a pitch for you in a second don't let me
forget uh let me just tell you now the
guy who um your friend you grew up with
who's like a lawyer or a insurance guy
who believes he could have had your
career like the people that are like oh
I could have done comedy and then or
they'll be pitching you jokes and it's
just like so two black guys and you're
like okay but it's always most effective
friend who's always trying to pitch me
on something and he'll like write it out
and I'll send it and then I'll wait for
like the the next like layer
I love him he's a great kid but it's
like you every time he like pitches it
you're just like
famous girls like Dad who was a dadager
yeah and he was like uh he's like yeah
man you can't say anything anymore I'm
like how would you no you can't say
anything you say and then you would be
like you know so an Asian a black guy
and a woman and you're like oh my god
dude I'm good yeah oh when people like
really want you to know it's not an ad
um like hey you guys not not an ad I
just honestly I just like love just
water no but it's always stuff that
doesn't need to advertise it's always
like you guys I swear this is not an ad
but like Vicks VapoRub is the most
amazing you're like it's been around it
is funny but it's also funny to be like
oh so every time you do an ad you don't
believe in that bullshit either we know
deep down you don't but it's funny now
we look at your ads and be like oh this
is just a paycheck that is such a
fucking good point
um and then uh not an ad that's such a
good point it's like not an ad you guys
McDonald's they don't need you but apple
cider vinegar is really good I'm like
they're not hiring influencers it is
funny yeah you see that so up you guys
not an ad but like Tiger Bomb is this
like who would hire you to do that yeah
yeah just like defensively like not an
ad right like I paid for these myself
yeah like the defensive something that
it doesn't need Bose headphones not an
ad so good yeah you guys yeah yeah it's
like not an ad unless you want to it's
yeah
not an ad you guys but Spencer's Gifts
is the greatest yeah
you guys not an ad but Barnes Noble is
incredible yeah I think we're gonna
react when they're like this isn't
enough there's no promo code what then
how can I get it if there's no promo
code I wish it was an ad
I only follow you for I love the
commercials you're making me sit through
content I just want to see the apps yeah
yeah go who thinks basic stuff is not an
ad but but it's your way of saying like
I have integrity guys not I just don't
do this out of the kindness of my own
heart I just want you to know it's also
very cocky for you to be like my opinion
is what you need to hear this whatever
the fuck oh you know water or coffee is
so good you need to listen to me and
that's not even that I'm getting paid
for that's not even I have like I'm not
even qualified to tell you this and I
haven't been and I and this is my
opinion I want to do with something
really shitty just be like dude Top
Ramen the shrimp flavor not an ad fire
yeah I think noodles fire because it's
also saying not an ad is like saying
like yeah first of all people are gonna
tune out if it's not one like I know you
guys only love commercials but it's like
the idea of going like not an ad it's
just so like
you guys you're about to hear me do
something truthful yeah I think you
should have to post your Instagram story
and then it doesn't post for an hour and
then an hour goes by and you have to
re-watch your story and go do you really
want to post that you really need to
tell the people like a breathalyzer yeah
do you really need to tell the people
about how good this random coffee shop
is in in Williamsburg yeah and then
you're gonna you go you go I'm at this
coffee shop I'm at this person and
you're supposed to like I cannot believe
that they're invading our privacy and
taking our data i'm like bitch you are
the one that invades your own privacy
you're the one that tells everyone where
you are your Geotech is literally your
apartment have you done
um
like religious person that's religious
when it's convenient mm-hmm
I feel like that's like a lot of like
the younger people that are like super
religious is like you'll see him at
fucking Burning Man and they're doing
like all these drugs and then you get
home and they're like can you not take
Jesus name in vain can you capitalize
the word God yeah yeah there's something
that's just sort of like you need this
to undo all the shitty shit you like
you're dragging me into your guilt shame
cycle yeah just the idea of like I
remember one time this girl super
religious actress
um who's like has been married like six
times and like who cares that stuff
doesn't mean you can't be right with God
but I remember she came up to me to
party I remember like it was yesterday
and she went so
how are your life choices
you're like if you're asking me not
great
you have to ask yeah okay I was gonna
say clearly you muted me because they're
terrible
um but just like the most subtle way
that that sometimes people like
religious people or someone that just
discovered something yeah someone that
just discovered something like dude you
gotta check this out how long have you
been doing it 24 hours okay so I've got
this you know what I mean it's just like
yeah yeah when everyone has to be an
evangelist for their thing right I have
a buddy who's like that every time I'd
see him was something new he got a snake
he got a guitar he was making t-shirts
he's like always a new thing but it's
like what why not just stick to one of
you good at one I don't know
get good at snake dude you gotta get
good at snake gotta get great at snake
get out that Nokia
I really like you man thank you Winnie
that is a a compliment can you tell it's
great riffs it's gonna respect you I
like you it was just uh I did uh shows
in Edmonton with Ricky and Ricky was
talking about touring with you and Ricky
Velez yeah the best very funny the
greatest but yeah I mean yeah thanks I
mean I mean I mean I think there's great
chemistry and um are you gonna do a
special soon we're gonna shoot at the
end of this and we're gonna pay for
yourself yeah probably pay for yourself
unless that's it nice see what happens
but um yeah like if you ever want to get
drinks or something you know like let me
know okay I don't know I hear your
house no I like I would
I will be friends with you let's do it
let's hang out I spend most of my energy
trying to not be friends with that you
know I'm just not taking on new I'm not
I'm at capacity on friends that is the
most La thing I've ever heard I am at
capacity with friends mentally and
physically I just am like there's a
certain you can't there's so much I do
feel that there's so many sparkly
amazing people but I just I don't go on
Hikes with people anymore just to find
out that they're like you know it is
weird you're Midway through a hike and
they're just literally you're just like
I feel like we should loop around the
coyotes right yeah just exactly or so
whatever the fuck it is and it's just
like and they're like so I'd like to
give you a pamphlet I'm outside you're
just like oh yeah but I really I'm a fan
of yours thank you Winnie that's so nice
I'm a fan of yours too so you're really
like you're just I'm just trying to be a
genuine guy I just I just love comedy
care about and that's it what am I
you're a good egg coming from someone
with one good egg I feel like I have the
authority to weigh in on this thank you
I appreciate it
well a woman named Emily is silencing me
um you're welcome so we got the best
part out we got the best part out I'm a
good egg okay so if you're still
listening at this part you are loyal and
you're a good fan it's all right
elephants thank you Trevor where's she
going she's leaving do you want to
plug your tour I sign off yeah like tell
us about your sign off with your tour
your what what do you want to yeah what
do you want people to check out let me
give it to you straight okay this
Whitney lady complete bitch all right
everybody goes on here being like Oh
it's such a good time no I'm kidding
obviously I had a great time nobody's
awesome I I told the story on my podcast
if Sox check it out about how I
discovered Whitney was like in college I
was in a fraternity and my senior year
it was the first time I ever had my own
TV in my life and I was I came back from
like a party I was a little buzz I was
flipping through Comedy Central and uh
her one of her specials was on and I
remember watching it being like it's
just the most Alpha bro energy I was
like yo this chick's funny and I just
remember being like like it was but it
was like so like you know I were just
talking about like not an ad like I
remember like going up to my friends and
I said I'd be like do you ever heard
this chick winning Comics this is super
funny so really cool to be doing that I
mean she's amazing hilarious
um yeah she did our podcast stiff socks
just came out today which is whenever
this comes out I'm on tour triple
wallscomedy.com are you that guy tour
coming to a city near you I mean it's
anywhere from east west south coast all
the coast
appreciate you for having me on man
um that's really all I want to plug I
post sketches every week and uh thanks
for having me great thanks Trevor don't
run elephants
one more time don't ride elephants don't
ride elephants I thought it was a promo
code oh Trevor promo code sucks where
you guys are still talking yeah
much he liked you I was like come on oh
yeah sorry I gotta go
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]